we got the story from timcast.com
intelligence whistleblower says U.S
government has retrieved craft of
non-human origin official provided
congress with information confirming
that multiple agencies are reverse
engineering the craft within top secret
programs
David Charles grush a veteran of the
National geospatial Intelligence Agency
and National reconnaissance office is
acting as a whistleblower and says the
information on these programs has been
illegally withheld from Congress
according to an exclusive report from
the debrief Russia's disclosures reveal
it for decades the U.S government acting
in concert with allies and defense
contractors has recovered intact
vehicles and partially intact vehicles
of exotic origin non-human intelligence
whether extraterrestrial or Unknown
Origin based on the vehicle morphologies
and material science Testing and the
possession of unique Atomic arrangements
and radiological signatures does it say
when they recovered it over the no just
says over the past few decades okay so I
can see if this thing crashed Justice
Biden is getting in trouble with the FBI
then I've got questions but if it's a
question just behind where the FBI was
speaking at their press conference she
says uh the UFO programs have been
concealed within multiple agencies
nesting unidentified aerial phenomena
it's unidentified a dominant autonomous
phenomena isn't it yeah oh no no no no
no anomalous anomalous yes unidentified
anomalous phenomena activities in
conventional secret access programs
without appropriate reporting to various
oversight authorities less than a week
before the debrief report was published
Nassau's first ever public hearing on
UFOs were members of a task force
created by the space agency discussed
findings from their investigations
of a person who's like who doesn't know
any of this is real but then they come
to you to be on the task force and
you're like and by the way aliens are
real it's like every movie ever yeah
it's like somebody has to be just like
you get hired you don't know they're
real and then some dude who works in
your department has to come to you and
be like by the way like aliens are real
we're going to ask you to ask us to work
with us on this everyone who works at
Nasa thinks aliens are real you can that
wrong
NASA this is other departments in the
government right
who who was the who was the guest on
Rogan he was on there a couple times I
think that that said that he worked in
this department
do you remember who I'm talking about
Serge I feel like surge knows yeah
you're not talking about that guy from
the 90s are you yeah yeah that's I'm
seriously yeah but that story seems to
be mostly bunk if you ask me really yeah
I forgot his name do you remember his
name
he said he saw a little green man and
then later on they were like why did you
say this like as a puppet and it's like
oh come on dude either was an alien or a
wasn't oh maybe I'm thinking of a
different person I'm not sure but he I
mean yeah he said he worked in a lab and
that they had this engineer yeah okay
okay well if he said he saw a little
green men remember yeah I can't remember
his name and look it up
[Music]
Bob Lazar there you go Chad's got us
covered they're they're smarter than we
are yes they know they have better
recollection I put uh Joe Rogan Little
Green Man guest into uh the search
engine it came up with Tom Green so I
don't know what I found interesting
about this article is that they said
that the main reason they were
disclosing it is because they wanted to
prove that it has not been the US that
has been suppressing this information
for the past 50 years they said that
this is a worldwide phenomenon and that
most countries or most governments
around the world have the same
information and and no one's talking
about it and I think that's absolutely
fascinating listen that the kind of the
like one of the theories it's like
conspiracy theories are hard to like
it's hard to believe in conspiracy
theories because the idea that that many
people could uni you know uniformly
quiet is hard to believe right so am I
supposed to believe that some nation
that wants into the UN and has alien has
evidence of aliens isn't going to use
that as some type of uh you know like
Leverage Point like let us in or we're
going to tell everybody about the aliens
unless the U.N is like no we don't talk
about the aliens so if you want into the
U.N you don't talk about well that's
what I'm saying good we won't yeah he's
saying you blackmail your way in yeah or
whatever what if the aliens took over a
long time ago and everything we think
about public life is just orchestrated
for the facilitation it's kind of like
you know chickens in a chicken coop you
show up you do the thing chickens have
no idea what's going on but you make
them think something's happening
it's a distinct possibility that we've
been I mean like there's no real war
there's like there is a war but it's
being done on for some specific purpose
the lockdowns were for some for some
specific purpose yeah well a global
event a lot of people think that the
lockdowns were a product of an effort to
be able to cover up the the printing
press that was necessary or the printing
that was necessary to deal with the uh
the collapse of the financial system
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah the uh if
you look at the the monetary charts from
the Great Recession from 2008 from the
crash it's there's a massive spike in
the in the influx of and printing of
money the expansion of the money supply
and then covet is boom right well there
was the the reason that people think
this is that late 2019 I think it was
November of 2019 the overnight lending
rate between uh central banks like
spiked massively and and that signals
oftentimes uh you know a contagion event
that's happening where no one is
trusting anybody to lend money basically
you have liquidity dry up and then you
have to turn on the printing press but
you have to have an excuse to do so
without the entire economy collapsing so
that's where the Cove would roll out I
don't necessarily buy it but it's an
interesting thesis
so the idea is that it's just it covers
up for the fact that there would be
Panic if they just turned it on for no
reason exactly okay well and and because
you shut down the economy you you
essentially like you give people a total
distraction you think that every like
you would have never been able to get
permission to print I think it was four
and a half or five trillion dollars in
2020. uh I don't think you could have
ever gotten that permitted unless it was
like an alien invasion or a pandemic
well that means next time we get the
alien infection honestly I think it's
probably In Our Lifetime we've talked
about it uh that the financial plan was
a was to prevent a hard fall to create a
slow fall so instead of the whole system
just breaking overnight and everyone
losing their minds which would destroy
everything right they make it a slow
fall and control The Descent
and then things are slowly getting worse
economically and in cities but it's
better than one day you have a city and
the next day you have just riots in the
city being burned down well the the
persistent inflation that's a product of
the lockdowns and the printing that
happened in 2020 uh I don't think people
understand how you know
deleterious I think that's the word that
is for civilization you know to have
have so many young people that now feel
as if they can't afford to ever purchase
a home and they're not wrong many of
them and I just think that that once you
have essentially dispirited uh all of
the young men and women of course
um in Civilization it's like well then I
I think that you suddenly you set your
inclusion yes I'm very woke I had to
include the lady here
um I think that once once you've gotten
to that position well then then the
potential for Wars as distraction be
increases exponentially because you have
so many people that are are purposeless
and you know yeah disenfranchise it's
terrible it's like a whole subsect of
memes that's like it says like um my
biggest mistake was being in the third
grade during the 2008 financial crisis
so I couldn't buy a home yeah like yeah
that's uh that's how it is for a lot of
people and I think you're right like
it's funny because I'm one of those
people when whenever I would hear people
talk about their annoyances with the
Boomers right like you you know go to
college and pay for your college on your
summer job which they don't understand
that is just not a possibility anymore I
would still get annoyed with the people
who are doing that because I'm like look
I'm not saying that they're not stupid
for talking like that and being clearly
devoid of reality now but I do get
annoyed when people don't take
responsibility for their own actions and
just complain about it but the more this
happens the more you're like yeah most
of us aren't going to be able to afford
a house in our lifetime and it's it's
just getting worse yeah and if you can't
afford a house how do you start a family
if you can't move forward in any way
what is to stop essentially civilization
from falling apart and if you if you
don't have kids if you don't have a
reason to to plan for the future or to
to actually focus on the biggest
problems that face us as a people
because you're now thinking about your
kids and your grandkids basically your
entire progeny
um well then you start to have really
what's called High Time preference
Behavior where you start to borrow and
live in debt and you're not you're not
so much worried about your health or or
achieve achievement or starting a
business or doing anything and and I
think that once you have that formula
well then America as the leader of the
world is essentially a memory in
Hollywood and all these industries are
telling you to live in the now don't
start a family and just indulge your
everywhere yeah it's complete
self-indulgence culture but you can
understand why if you are being told
we'll go to college and go into massive
amounts of debt to never be able to
afford anything to work for Soulless
companies that don't represent your
values and ultimately will chew you up
and spit you out it's not a that's not a
fun time and even if they do represent
your values it's still a soulless
corporation that you have no connection
to why so you can work your way up to
middle management fantastic you can be
known on the internet and not know
anyone around you exactly this is an
apartment complex this is why it's so
important that that in my opinion that
the Libertarians lead the way in
educating as to what Central Banking
does to an economy and to a civilization
and and so few people understand it
really in depth that they they they
misattribute the blame to Capital ISM
this is not capitalism when you have a
central bank by its very nature you
don't have capitalism right away because
you have the capacity to control the
most important Market signal there is
which is both the quantity of currency
as well as the interest rate so the
price that you pay for that currency
it's it's devastating to an economy and
ultimately to a culture and this is a
product this is a a trend that has
persisted when it comes to Central
Banking throughout Western Civilization
for thousands of years and yet if you
bring it up to somebody that's recent
college grad they'll just be like no
it's the greedy Goldman it's like no no
those dudes are a product of Central
Banking BlackRock and it's nine trillion
dollars is a product of Central Banking
if you think they do that because
they're not educated like they don't
have any kind of financial literacy they
don't understand economics the schools
are teaching them different that's
really the problems that schools don't
teach us at all they prefer to pad their
education with like gender expression or
whatever well I mean the primary thing
if you get any economics education in
you know Academia it's going to be
Marxist leaning which is always you know
aiming from Jump Street to undermine and
and debase what actual free market
capitalism is which is just voluntary
trade amongst people it doesn't really
have anything to do with the government
at all but then they they met they
managed to essentially suppress any
knowledge about Central Banking and what
that creates honestly most of them don't
even understand it I've had Jimmy Dore
on my show we talked about this at
length and I love Jimmy Dore I think
he's brilliant but when I talked to him
about it he's like look I don't
understand Central Banking and I was
like Jimmy
if you're going to talk about the
pitfalls of capitalism and you don't
understand understand Central Banking
well we got to go back to square one
brother like we got it because I I
honestly think that he and RFK and so
many of these guys that seem to
understand so much of the problems of
the world that the Libertarians identify
to ultimately their Solutions are wrong
because they don't understand the root
of the problem and and I don't say that
as a paternal way or a talking down way
I just mean like I think that's honestly
the issue here is and he was he was uh
you know at least honest enough to admit
it that he's like I don't understand
Central Banking and a lot of these
issues have been convoluted so heavily
by the market like also it's like they
they blame capitalism but they're they
don't understand that what they're
talking about is actually cronyism
exactly and in the combination of
government
We Exist under an oligop oligopoly and
basically every Market sector and and
that's a product of both regulatory
capture as well as essentially a
fascistic Alliance that exists between
these businesses and the government and
the government Regulators as well as the
central bank and aliens and alien Tim
yeah I traded just trying to rope on the
regular people because they're probably
being like I'm not interested it's
starting to like two now but do aliens
have capitalism that's what we need to
know what do they probably understand
Central Banking how do they build those
ships aliens brought Central Banking
that means if you support Central
Banking you're supporting demons can't
oh even from the sky yeah and I'm pretty
sure it's in the Bible somewhere about
not having central banks or something
because Tim is a religious scholar I'm
gonna I'm gonna pivot a different way to
keep people's attention still if if we
didn't have Central Banking by now we
would all be flying in UFOs so they
abolish the Fed
that's why the aliens want us to
continue down the path of not
understanding Central Banking they want
to have it for themselves and no one
else because they're keeping the UFOs
maybe maybe the aliens came here to
control everything to destabilize the
economy so that we're forced to end the
central banking system
sounds good to me you're here to help
we must liberate these people and get
rid of their central banks and then you
know that's way more optimistic than
them just being here to probe me because
I didn't really want that most of the
time when I watch any show with aliens
or any movie with aliens and I look at
that look at their ship I'm like how did
they build that ship like that's the
number one question I asked like they
got tentacle arms and like they can't
hold tools how do they build the ship
that's what I want to know they hold
sticks with little fingers on them they
got 3D printers I figure by that point
like just massive 3D printers that's
just 3D printed this will always gets me
about everything alien like at some
point we can only understand them
through the through the lens of our own
understanding of humanity right so we're
like how do they build the ship like how
do we know on their Planet they don't
just grow ships like if alien species
exist they're probably so different from
us like there was some show like hunt
for aliens or whatever and some guy was
like I worked at Area 51 and I'm very
knowledgeable and he's describing like
just weird looking humans like he's
saying they walked on two legs like why
would an alien be the similar shaped
which doesn't make any sense to me
that's why I really need this to get
Declassified because I want to
understand it just sounds like we are
trying to read our own Humanity into
something else it's more likely that
some dude got drunk and was stumbling
home from a bar and then came across a
goofy looking dude and was like wow look
at this guy he's got a big head and big
eyes and oh and then he passes out then
he wakes up a few hours later and he's
like what what time is it and he looks
at his his watch or his phone he's like
two hours
two hours are gone but I was just at the
bar and then I told everybody like it
was like it was 2 A.M and then all of a
sudden I blink and it's like 4 a.m and
there was this big headed thing I swear
it must have been an alien it's like
dude were you drinking you're like
that's irrelevant blackout
and did you just see some guy with a big
head
that's just infinitely more plausible
than actually aliens coming abducting
people unfortunately but he's like quick
quick the Biden family is corrupt
you know it's really crazy yeah right
you know what's really crazy is like
imagine what a duck must be thinking
when it lands near a decoy duck it's
just like this dude duck is like this
chick ain't saying nothing she's just
standing there this is kind of weird but
I don't know that's all right by me and
then imagine if aliens did come here
would they have some kind of decoys are
there like Android human decoys that
walk around yes it's Mark Zuckerberg no
it's or it's the NPCs those people with
no inner monologue that we hear about
now that just walk around and they just
exist without actually thinking I think
I honestly think that study has to be
wrong because I think people just don't
know what it means to think yeah because
they have to they have to think they
vote they're thinking they're vocalizing
in their head differently than we are I
guess would be the best the fact that
they don't understand it isn't
concerning no of course of course
Paladin did like a really like deep dive
breakdown into that study that explained
more or less what it meant but yeah I
still like the idea that there's people
that just walk around that just don't
think about anything because I overthink
about literally everything because I'm
doing like I'm going to open the door
I'm like is it left or is it right and
I'm thinking about this all the way to
the door handle and it would be
imagining people that don't think at all
it would be a cheat code for like the
highest level of meditation if you have
no inner monologue because you're just
already in the Zen State yeah
I've been trying for years I can't get
it empty your mind it's like Beavis and
Butthead yeah did you watch the new one
they have new episodes oh yeah the green
button they're actually really funny and
they're they're meditating and he's like
you have to empty your mind enter an
enlightened State and then all of a
sudden they just start floating up to
like ascending into a higher plane
because their brains are in it or
something and then like they get there
and there's like religious figures and
great philosophers and they just like
their brains don't work people don't
know this about Tim but he does
incredible impersonations you were you
like recapping an entire episode where
we were playing poker on Friday of
Beavis Butthead and I was like I felt
like Mike Judge was in the room oh I
don't know I don't think I'm
particularly good at weaves oh no you
are you are thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time